directed acyclic graphs are a special
class of graphs that really haven't
warrant the theory of their own of
course directed acyclic graphs is a lot
of syllables so they're called eggs for
short okay so here's where is why they
come up all the time let's look at a
diagram that may be familiar to you this
shows the prerequisite structure of
required courses in the 6-3 program of
MIT electrical engineering and computer
science department there are similar
charts for the other sub majors of EECS
and in other departments as well so what
does it mean well let's look at this
vertex corresponding to the first term
calculus class 1801 and there's an edge
that points to 60 42 and that's because
if you look at the catalog 6042 lists
1801 as a prerequisite if you look at
the algorithms introductory algorithms
class six double O six you'll find if
you look in the catalog that it has
listed two prerequisites 6042 and 601
and the fact that that they're
explicitly listed in the catalog as
prerequisites is why there's an arrow
from 60 16 double oh sixty-seven you
want to take six double 06 of course
it's you have to attend and not just the
fact that you have to take 60 for to
first and 60 one first but you've got to
take the prerequisites of those
prerequisites for so you really have to
take 1801 before you can take six double
06 and you need to take 80 two before
you can take six double 06 there are
co-requisites here let's just ignore
those and pretend that they were
prerequisites because they're kind of
another kind of arrow that don't even
distract us okay so that's what the this
diagram is telling us and this is a dag
um it's simply a bunch of vertices the
course labels in in rectangular boxes
and and directed arrows showing catalog
listings and what I said was that when
you're planning your coursework you're
really interested in the indirect
prerequisites so one class you is an
indirect prerequisite of another class
VIII means that there's a sequence of
requisites starting from you and going
to V it means that you really have to
have taken you some time before you took
V and that's a crucial fact and think
that you need to take account of when
you're planning a course schedule so in
terms of graph digraph language you is
an indirect prerequisite of V just means
that there's a positive length walk that
goes from u to V in the digraph in this
case we're talking about the 6-3 digraph
of prerequisites so there's a positive
length walk from 1801 to six double 060
means that you really have to have taken
1801 before you take six double o 6 and
of course we're talking then about the
positive length walk relation the plus
of the digraph d if d is the digraph
shown in the prerequisite your direct
prerequisite chart then we're interested
in D plus and you d plus V just means
there's a positive length walk that's
what the plus is for going from u to V
now what happens if you have a closed
walk well a closed walk is a walk that
starts and ends at the same vertex um
and we can ask this question suppose
there was a closed walk that started at
60 for two and end in it 60 for two how
long does it take to graduate then well
it takes a long time because you can't
take 60 for two until you've taken 60
for two and you're never going to be
able to take it that's a bad thing we
definitely don't want the prerequisite
of structure of courses in the
department to have a closed walk of
positive length and in fact there's a
faculty committee that checks for this
kind of thing it bugs like this
occasionally creep in when some busy
curricular office of a department is
planning a complicated program with
dozens if not 100 courses and the
committee on curriculars job is to check
for that kind of thing this whole staff
it does it I used to be the chair of
that committee and we did spend a lot of
time with proposals from departments and
making sure that those proposed course
requirements satisfied faculty rules
okay so a special case of a closed walk
is a cycle a cycle is a walk whose only
repeat vertex is it start and end and
and let me remark because we keep
talking about positive length cycles
that a single vertex will by itself is a
length zero cycle so you're never going
to be able to get rid of length zero
cycles cause the same they're the same
as vertices but positive length cycles
you can hope to ensure are not there so
if you're going to represent the cycle
as a path you'd show the sequence of
vertices and edges v-0 v1 v2 where the
understanding is that all of the
vertices from v-0 up to VN minus 1 and
different that's what makes it a cycle
except that the last vertex V 0 is a
repeat of the first one that's the one
repeat that's allowed in a cycle so it's
naturally draw it in a in a circle like
this where you started v-0 you follow
the edges around from VI tu VI plus 1
all the way back around to v-0 and
that's kind of what a cycle is going to
look like so we have a very
straightforward lemma about cycles and
closed walks namely that the shortest
positive length closed walk from a
vertex to itself it's closed means it
starts and ends at V is a positive
length cycle starting and ending at V
and the reasoning and proof is basically
the same proof that said that the
shortest walk between one place and
another is a path from one place to the
other the logic is that if I have a
closed walk from V to V and there was a
repeat in it other than at V I could
clip out the piece of the walk between
the repeat occurrences and I'd get a
shorter walk so the close the shortest
closed walk can't have any repeats it's
got to be a positive ones cycling so it
directed acyclic graph now is defined
simply as a positive as a digraph that
has no positive length cycles it's a
cyclic no positive length cycles and of
course we can equally well define it
since cycles or a special case of closed
works and closed works of positive
length employ cycles as a digraph that
has no
positive length closed walk some
examples of tags that come up well the
prerequisite graph um is going to be one
and in general any kind of set of
constraints on tasks that you have to do
which ones you have to do before you do
other ones is going to be defining a a
dag structure a one that you might not
have thought of is the successor
function defines a relation on the
integers say going from n to n plus one
so I'm going to have an arrow that goes
directly from n to n plus 1 and what's
the work relation then the positive
length walk relation in this graph well
there's a positive length walk from n2m
precisely when n is less than M so the
successor dag its pads represent the
less than relation and of course less
than it doesn't have any cycles because
if a is less than B you're never going
to get around from be back to something
that's less than it like back to a so
there can't be any cycles in the
successor dag and that's why it is a dag
another similar one is the proper subset
relation between sets so here I'm going
to draw an arrow from this set to that
said if this set is contained in that
set and but they're not equal so a B is
a subset of a BD but but a BD has this
extra element D so the left-hand set is
a proper subset at the right hands said
and I'm going to draw an arrow there and
by the same reasoning there can't be any
cycles in this graph positive length
cycle because if there was it would mean
that the the set had to be a proper
subset of itself which doesn't happen so
this would be another basic example of a
dag and you know I hope you begin to see
from these examples why the eggs are
really or pervasive and in mathematics
and in other areas and why they merit
attention so when we're looking at a
deck though we're basically usually
interested in just the walk relation of
the deck so that if we're only
interested in the walk relation of the
deck then I it would be typically the
case that many different tags are going
to have
same work relation and it's natural to
ask what's the most economical one is
there a minimum say dag that defines a
give and walk relation so let's look at
this example here's a simple tag and you
can check that there are no cycles in it
um what's the smallest dag with the same
relation as this one and the way I can
get it is by going through the edges one
at a time and asking whether I can get
rid of the edge because it's not
contributing anything so look here
there's a path from a to b to e that
goes through be well that tells me that
having this direct edge from A to E is
not contributing anything in terms of
connectedness and that means I could get
rid of it and I'm still going to wind up
with the same possibility of walking
from one place to another because I can
always walk from A to E going through be
instead of going directly from 80 I
didn't need that edge another example is
here's a walk from A to D that goes
through see there's no need for me to
walk directly from A to D as long as I'm
walking I can take the longer walking
and get rid of the short circuit from A
to D likewise if i look at this path
from C to D to F I don't need that edge
from C to F and as a matter of fact now
if I look at this length 3 path from A
to C D to F there's no need for me in
order to get from A to F there's no need
for me to take the direct edge I can get
rid of that too it's kind of a redundant
extra edge finally if i look at the path
from B to D to F I can get rid of the
direct edge from b2f and at this point
i'm i'm done i'm left with the set of
edges called covering edges which have
the property that are the only way to
get from a one vertex to another is
going to have to be to use a covering
edge to the target vertex or more
precisely the only way to get from safe
from A to B is going to be to use that
covering edge if there was any other
path that meant from a elsewhere and got
back to be without using this edge then
it wouldn't be a covering edge anymore
the fact that it's a covering edge means
that if you broke it there's no way
anymore to get from A to B so that's the
definition of covering edges
do a class problem about them or
precisely in minutes so the the other
edges are unneeded to define the walk
relation and all we need to keep on the
covering relations to get the minimum
representation of the walk relation in
terms of a dag